There is no one who likes
you hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha of Catalina
I want to go out with you because I'm in love with you I told you
clearly Slugger Maria
You're not going to marry anyone, are you?
It's Katarina-sama who wants
to be by your side, so please let me stay by your side
forever.  Open up, I'm with everyone,
even Katarina-sama, please let me
be with you forever
.
That's right, Mr. Uji Old, I've
said this many times, but I can't serve as the prince's term as a
specialty.  So
nume Sora can't sit with anyone and ends up with
good friends who don't have 3. As a layer game, it's a good
way to split the bag
.